كله تجربه سياسيه تستوجب همم تخطيطا
والتفكيرا وتستوجب كوادر وتستوجب قدرات
وهذه لم يكن يملكها
التيارات التي صعدت بعد الثوره لانها
تكونت على عجل ولان شبابها لم يكونوا
قادرين على ان يستوعبوا الواقع ويدركم
الواقع ويفهموا ما المطلوب منهم وان
الكثيرين قد فتحوا خصومات عقائديها
وخصومات ايديولوجيا ايوه بقى ان ينكبوا
على معالجه الواقع والسعيدي تغييره علما
بان اداره الشان العام ليست قضيه سهله هي
قضيه تستوجب معرفه تستوجب قدرات تستوجب
تخطيطا وهذا لم يتوفر لحركه النهضه في
تونس كما لم يتوفر لكثير من الحركات
السياسيه الاخرى ولذلك في تصوري الفشل كان
فشل دريعا للجميع بالتفاوت المسؤوليه فيه
يقيننا لو وضعناها كذلك في نفس الاطار مع
تجربه الاخوان المسلمين في مصر همم سيد
عبد الفتاح ايضا كان الفشل هو العنوان
الرئيسي لهذه التجربه تجربه الحكم هل
تتشابه يعني عوامل الفشل عند الاخوان
المسلمين مع عوامل الفشل ام ان هناك فرق
بينهما نتحدث بين التجربه المصريه
والتجربه التونسيه بعد الربيع العرب
انا احتجز من الجواب في هذه النقطه لاني
اخذت على نفسي الا اتدخل في اي شان هذا
شان سياسي يتعلق ببلد المحترمه ونقدره
ونقدر ماضيه حاضره وننتظر منه مستقبلا ان
يكون في مقدمه النهضه الاسلاميه والنهضه
العربيه وان يقوده في المنطقه ولذلك احترس
عن الاجابه اولا احتراما لما حصل في مصر
وما يحصل ثانيا لان المعطيات المتوفره لدي
ليست كافيه تجعلني قادرا على ان احكم
واقيم لكن في ال- في ال- همم في المشهد
المنظور انه هناك نقص عديده حصلت من الذين
تولوا السلطه بعد الثوره
2011 ادت الى هذا الانسداد انسداد الافاق
سواء في وطني او في كثير من اوطان العرب
وتحركت الشعوب ولكنها لم تكن على هدى في
تحركها وهذا يحتاج منا الى تقييم جديد
لواقع التحرك الشعبي هل ان شعوبنا اليوم
قادره بما لديها من امكانيات على ان تختص
لنفسها طريق الخلاص من هذا التخلف الذي
نعيش جميعا والذين مشوا والذي تحدثنا عنه
منذ قرن التاسع عشر القرن ال 20 وابين ان
نبقى تابعين لغيرنا وتحدث كل المصلحين في
اوطاننا على ان مال العرب والمسلمين ينبغي
ان يتحول الى مركز مرموق في العالم لكننا
لم نحقق ذلك الى الان ينبغي ان نسال
انفسنا ما الذي نقصنا في هذا التاريخ
على ان ناخذ مكانه انا اريد ان افهم لانه
يعني لا نريد ان انت لا نريد ان تتحدث عن
الشان المصري يعني تحديدا لكن اضعها في
الحكم الاسلامي حكم هذه الجماعات
الاسلاميه لماذا فشلت يعني اين يكمن الخطا
في هذه التجارب التي حكمت فتره من الفترات
ثم الان
اصبحت يمكن في في سجون لفظها الشعب وهذا
المشهد يعني وحاضر وواضح في اكثر من بلد
عربي واسلام
سيد الكريم كلمه الحكم كلمه سهله عن
اللسان
لكننا في الحقيقه هي هي مسار ينبغي ان
تتوفر شروط نجاحه
الحكم والقدره على فهم الواقع الذي نعيش
المؤثرات فيه من يحكمون من داخلنا من
يتحكم في اوضاعنا الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
من خارجنا نحن كخيرنا من الشعوب معرضون
الى تاثير والى تاثير قوي من الذين يصنعون
والذين يبدعون الذين يطعموننا والذين
يكسوننا والذين يقدمون لنا حاجيات زمننا
هم من خلال ذلك لهم سلطان لا اقول مباشر
ولكن لا هم سلطان علينا حتى على المستوى
الادبي هل نحن قدرنا على ان ناخذ لانفسنا
باسباب عزتنا ومجدنا وان نكتسب لانفسنا
ما اكتسبوهم في قرون نهضتهم الثلاث او
الاربع التي سبقت القرن العشرين نحن اليوم
نتحدث عن تغيير في اوطاننا
ثلثوا شعوبنا لا تحسن القراءه والكتابه
نحن معزولون عن العلوم الانسانيه الموجوده
في العالم نحن لا نقرا نحن لا نتعلم نحن
لم نفتح كلياتنا ولا بنفتح مجتمعاتنا نحن
لم ندرح حوارا بين نخبنا وشعوبنا كيف يمكن
ان نتحدث عن حكم ونحن عاجزون عن ان يغفر
الاقل القليل مما ذكرت لا اجد شعبا قادرا
على ان يخطط لنفسه طريقا اذا لم يكن
متعلما واذا لم يكن واعيا واذا لم يكن له
صله بواقعه الذي يعيش ونحن معزولون عن هذا
لان عق اتعيش ماضيا سحيقا كنا اعزه فيه
وكل ما سئلنا عن واقعنا
تحدثنا عن ماضينا
وكاننا نعتبر ان ماضي انا العزيز وقدراتنا
السابقه تكفينا لان نكون اليوم في صداره
العالم مع النواقع الدنيا يقول خلاف ذلك
اذن نحن نحتاج الى هذا الوعي اذا هذا
الادراك الى هذا التغيير العميق في نفوسنا
حتى نقبل على اسباب العزه اذا كان الاسلام
قال لنا قبل ان يشرع لنا الحلال والحرام
اقرا
فكيف يمكن ان نبدع ونحن لا نقرا ونحن لا
نتعلم وعلوم العصر بعيده عنا عقولنا لا
تستوعب علوم العصر علوم العصر النفسيه
والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
والاداريه والرياضيه التي ابدعها غيرنا
نحن لا نسهم فيها ولا نشارك بين ما يمكن
ان يدفع الى التقدم بها حيث يمكن ان نتحدث
عن حكم